bilder vom morgen beiruts hafen eine
trümmerwüste teile der millionenstadt
zerstört sogar sieben kilometer vom
explosionsort entfernte häuser werden
verwüstet berichten uns augenzeugen
beirut gestern abend kurz nach 18 uhr
ein brand in einem lagerhaus im hafen
löst zwei gewaltige explosionen aus eine
druckwelle rast durch die stadt
sie ist so enorm dass es menschen
kilometer entfernt von den beinen reist
tausende sind verletzt viele verschonen
ganze straßenzüge verwüstet bilder wie
nach einem luftangriff
mein auto wurde plötzlich gegen die
abgrenzung geschleudert die scheiden
sind geborsten
die splitter haben nicht verletzt das
ist von meinem auto übrig geblieben
beirut im schockzustand die regierung
ruft zu blutspenden auf wirtschaftskrise
staat bankrott dann die korona pandemie
es gibt kaum noch krankenhäuser die die
vielen verletzten versorgen könnten eine
stadt im ausnahmezustand lebt keine
verletztenzahl nennen aber es wurden
mehr patienten eingeliefert
als wir behandeln können wir haben tote
schwer leicht verletzte
die löscharbeiten dauern die ganze nacht
es ist eine katastrophe in einem land
das am abgrund steht
[Musik]